a 40 km de la capital de islandia
reykjavík lava al rojo vivo y columnas
de humo salen de una fisura volcánica
para deleite de los intrépidos turistas
que estaban allí y presenciaron una
escena espectacular
he esperado años y años para ver la lava
es el objetivo de mi vida
y cuando llegamos a esa colina decidimos
bajar vamos a acercarnos y es un riesgo
y lo sabemos pero lo vamos a hacer
creo que voy a llorar porque es muy
bello y muy emotivo maus la erupción en
la península de réquiem ee se produjo
tras un periodo de intensa actividad
sísmica con unos 10.000 terremotos
detectados desde el sábado hasta el año
pasado en la zona no había experimentado
una erupción desde el siglo 13 se cree
que la actividad volcánica de este año
es entre 5 y 10 veces más fuerte que la
de 2021
tienes los cráteres abiertos tienes la
fuente de lava y luego la lava que fluye
que en realidad también está empujando
la arena y la tierra delante de sí misma
así que esto es realmente espectacular
me gusta mucho
las autoridades islandesas evalúan los
peligros incluso la posible
contaminación por gas al tiempo que
emitieron advertencias para los
visitantes los geofísicos afirman que la
actividad reciente podría marcar el
inicio de un nuevo período de erupciones
que duraría siglos